hey guys Dr Burke here in this video
we're going to share with you how to
heal your acne I wish I would have known
this when I was going through high
school I had really bad skin so I'm
going to share with you what to do
there's several factors that will affect
the skin but primarily we're going to
talk about the anatomy of something
called a sebaceous gland what is a
sebaceous gland it's a little gland on
in your skin you have that in your hair
you have them all over the place um but
you don't have them over the soles of
your feet in different places but
basically if this clan is
malfunctioning you will have acne
blackheads whitee heads oily skin dry
skin you can have any combination and so
let's start with the vitamin A if your
vitamin A is low you're going to have
problems with this gland vitamin A
controls and regulates this gland in
your skin so without vitamin A your skin
can be really really bad there's a
couple factors need to know though about
what what happens at the cellular level
vitamin A can kill unfriendly bacteria
in your skin and so one of the myths
that people have is that they think they
have to just scrub out these black heads
and white heads and scrub their face and
sterilize their face that's going to
damage your skin that's what I used to
do and it was incorrect because you have
a layer of friendly bacteria on your
skin that's supposed to be there to
protect you when you scrub too hard you
can destroy that also when you take
antibiotics you will destroy it as well
so I know people take uh antibiotics and
their skin gets better but if you can
just keep your good bacteria in your gut
healthy you don't have to go that route
um there's even a condition I mean a a
drug called Accutane which is a high
level of vitamin synthetic vitamin A
which is really good for the skin but it
has a lot of side effects so anytime
time you take a vitamin in high
potencies it it comes with a package
there's a lot of problems we don't want
to do that we want to take vitamin A
typically in its natural form not
synthetic okay I'll show you how what to
do so but vitamin A can control the
bacterial growth controls the oil coming
out of the skin the dryness and actually
it can get rid of acne um vitamin A
foods are you know people think of
carrots uh spinach kale anything orange
or yellow that's true but those vitamins
in the vegetable family are pre vitamin
A uh factors they're not active forms so
your body has to convert the previtamin
a to the active form and it's very
difficult for you to your body to do
that in many cases if you're lucky you
might convert 4 to 5% so you're really
not getting your vitamin A source from
the vegetable you're getting it from the
animal products that you eat and that's
why a vegetan Arian has a lot of dry
skin they have vitamin A deficiencies
which is dry eyes can't see at night
sinus problems things like that so the
best source of vitamin A that I would
recommend a natural source would be
codiv oil but not just any codiv oil you
want to get a civer oil that is um
virgin civer oil because when you get
traditional inexpensive cheap civer oil
you're basically getting a lot of
problems you're getting added vitamins
you're getting a heated product that
kills off all the good nutrition it's
refined it might have too much of One
Thing versus the other I don't like it
so there's a lot of problems with uh
just real cheap Civ oil I would get a
high quality virgin Civ oil and also as
a side note you probably have heard
about the fermented C oil right um now I
used to buy into that but as I was
studying it I realized you can't ferment
Cod oil you can't ferment an oil only a
carbohydrate so basically it's bogus and
when I bought the stuff it tastes very
very fishy because it's when you try to
ferment it you're going to cause a
rancidity or uh a souring effect and
it's going to go rancid so the cive oil
if it's fresh shouldn't shouldn't have a
bad smell but that's a really good
source of not just vitamin A but vitamin
D as well which we'll get to uh also uh
liver personally I like eating liver but
I just want to let you know that liver
has a lot of vitamin A but of course if
you're going to do liver do grass-fed
organic don't do just regular liver and
then um the other thing is butter Cary
gold butter is a really good source of
grassed butter and that has it's load
with vitamin A that would be a good
source of vitamin A and egg yolks
pasture raised egg yolks that's what I
would recommend I have a lot of those
that's really loaded with vitamin A so
vitamin A is very important and
regulating the sebaceous Glam and that's
the first thing you need to do I don't
recommend doing massively High potency
just fractionated vitamin A pills
because there's a toxicity problem with
that you're going to create deficiencies
in other things okay you have to really
know what you're doing um now next thing
is low vitamin D vitamin D is not just
for your bones it's not just for your
mood it's for your skin and guess where
you get this from the Sun and guess you
also can get it from the Civ oil so Civ
oil has a nice balance of vitamin d and
vitamin A but sun and despite what
you've been taught about sun sun is
actually very very healthy for the skin
and it doesn't cause skin cancer No in
fact Sun actually protects you against a
lot of types of skin cancer and other
cancers because the vitamin D actually
is good for the immune system now I'm
not saying lay out in the sun and get
completely leathered and like burnt
things like that I'm just talking about
a little bit of sun is really good for
the S skin so um V these two are really
important and vitamin all the fat C of
vitamins vitamin A d e k there's
something unique about them they have
the ability to be stored in fat and also
they have the ability to go through the
fat layer of the cell and into the
center of the cell where the DNA is and
they can affect the DNA a of the cell
and control your genes and that's why if
you're deficient in these fat Cy of
vitamins you can have a lot of
structural problems with your proteins
your body tissues okay so that's a
little bit different than the other
water soluable vitamins like vitamin B
things like that so vitamin D vitamin A
very important gallbladder I want to
mention that because if a person has a
congested gallbladder or a congested
liver or a bad liver or no gallbladder
what's going to happen happen is that
you're not going to have enough bile b i
l e bile is a fluid that kind of helps
you break down fats and fat Cal vitamins
so if you're consuming these and your
skin is not getting better it could be
that you just don't have enough support
from the gallbladder to absorb them into
the body so it's just something I always
look at when someone's taking these
things because you need to be able to
not just get it but absorb it okay next
thing androgens what is an androgen an
androgen is a hormone produced by your
stress gland your adrenal glands on top
of your kidney but it's also produced by
the ovary okay and the testicle but
mainly um this in a female is coming out
of the ovary and that during that time
of the month they might have a little
acne because they have a their ratio
they have a little too much Androgen
versus estrogen so if that happens
they'll get acne uh I have videos on how
to deal with that but guess what
triggers
androgens sugar yeah too much sugar so
if you were to have a problem with
androgens or other conditions called
polycystic ovarian syndrome if you don't
know what that is that's fine but if you
if you have it you know what I'm talking
about the best solution for that is to
get the sugar down to zero in your diet
okay and that will help you greatly so
there's two things that will increase
androgens one is sugar and the other
thing is stress okay so sugar and stress
really affect your your
skin then we have vitamin B5 what is B5
panthic acid panthic acid is a vitamin
that has that gives you nice clear skin
the problem is people take it
synthetically or they take too much of
it individually and then they create
deficiencies and other things like
Biotin and their hair starts getting
brittle so again I'm not saying go out
there and start taking massive dosages
just realize ize that vitamin B5 does
control the skin and you just need to
look at what depletes vitamin B5 and
that would be stress so again stress is
a factor that we want to start to deal
with and lower that to help your skin um
the other thing is insulin
insulin is a a hormone that regulates
blood sugars and insulin is triggered by
Sugar so and that's also in the hidden
sugars like breads pasta crackers biscus
waffles pancakes muffins sodas juice
alcohol all that will influence this
gland right here now these are really um
comprehensive things but if you have
acne you need things that you can do to
better your skin and not be stuck in a
situation where you're taking Accutane
or um some antibiotics so you want to be
able to look at all these to see maybe
what's missing in your diet if you're a
junk food junkie like I was then you
need to start consuming um these foods
and get the sugar out of the diet you
your skin will clear up nicely the other
thing that um I'm going to recommend is
that even though vegetables don't have
the active form of vitamin A you're
going to have to eat a large quantities
to get all the other nutrients the
minerals the other vitamins that make
these work and then clean out your liver
because you can't just you know live on
collor oil you know so I highly
recommend you eat the vegetables as well
the combination of that with some of
these things cutting the sugar out
trying to avoid the stress as much as
possible um that can greatly improve
your skin so go ahead and do these
things and then write your comments
below